do you have a clear vision of the ending
when you start a script or does it come
to you as a story progressive I have an
ending for not actually what happens but
how I want someone to feel so if I want
an audience to leave this feeling happy
and like wow that was just that just
uplifted my day I'm gonna keep that in
mind the whole time but I might not have
the scene that that goes with or how
exactly we get there because these
characters we're dealing with in a
moment are having an argument or
wherever it is but if I want them to
feel happy I'm always keeping it in mind
so I have to leave little pieces of that
throughout the film for us to get there
so I would say yes I would know the
ending of a film in in the mood in the
movie of like the mood or the feeling
but not necessarily how that happens
yeah you mentioned earlier watching the
audience which i think is really
fascinating because so many people are
in their own world these days at the
phone and they barely look up at the
screen sometime what what is that do
when you see someone that's so
entrenched in you can tell that it's
really affecting I mean I've sat next to
people who were just sobbing in a film
and I was like I don't know should I say
something to them I go bad for this
person no I'm gonna let him be you know
but seeing how cinema affects people how
does that affect you seeing how it
affects other people I'm very empathetic
I'm extremely empathetic like to like
almost I'm not can't think of fallouts
but it's all of affects me so I have to
put guards up for it so seeing an
audience being affected by art and film
or any any audience to anything even art
like an art gallery it affects me a lot
so if I look over and see someone like
crying I might cry so it affects me in a
way that I can almost by looking them
feel what they are feeling and then like
I said I can go back to the film and
think well what about this made them cry
and then bring the logic into it like
wow that made them cry I have no idea
that means it's a personal thing like
they might have a personal situation at
mirrors it because it's like a little
thing while they're crying pretty
aggressively for just you know this
pretty calm moment or they had the the
writers and the filmmakers were able to
put something in place to where we're
building you to a place that you don't
know it and then it hits you on the side
and then you see a more aggressive cry
than what you expect
I kind of try to then unpack that like
what happened here to get them to that
place or it's a the moment that's
actually happening right there and what
cinematography that they used to be able
to free the person enough to not feel
like they were in watching a movie
because that's necessary for someone to
cry in a way or laugh in a way that's
kind of freeing they have to not feel
like they're in a movie so how the
camera moved sometimes the camera is
moving too much and the person's like oh
like they're trying to follow something
or they feel like I'm watching a movie
rather than I feel engrossed so maybe
the camera kind of pushed in a little
bit and you felt like you connected a
little bit more with the character and
you felt like I understand them now I'm
going to cry because they're sad or
whatever it is that affects us in any
emotional way it's interesting to when
people laugh and sometimes there's only
just one person laughing at something
and it's it's very telling you know and
so it's interesting to see why people
laugh at something yeah comedy is tough
getting reactions in comedy that are
enough of a wide spread to hit most of
the audience because everyone thinks of
comedy it's different most people think
of pretty much the same things it's sad
scary whatever but funny that's hard we
all have such different personalities in
comedy but yet comedy is tough so
watching audience
be impacted and laughing their heads off
is always one of those moments for me
like I am totally gonna have to watch
this movie again cuz I want to see
what's happening here like you know so I
think watching comedies with a group of
people that don't know they're being
watched is just so much fun for me and
it teaches it teaches me a lot I mean I
started in comedy I mean I have a
psychological thriller right now and I'm
doing a lot of drama
but I started writing like slapstick
type stuff and making people laugh from
theater
um so getting to watch that in a in a
film setting a movie theater it feels
like the inner it's like they got it
like going back to the the church plays
yeah Church plays and community theater
I worked at a theater called hetro
theater up in Pennsylvania a little
weird theater weird in a good way
yeah and that was my first experience
with professional audiences and these
you know intellectuals that would come
to see the theater
and getting them to kind of loosen up
that that moment was something that I
looked for it's like we knew what we
were doing was right because it's that
moment where everyone came to be seen or
who's here and then all of a sudden
they're like leaving their chair they're
you know they're having a good time or
or they're just like leaning forward or
whatever it is that that's the moment
that's when you have an audience and
seeing it and theater makes it easier to
understand it and film because there's
no audience there but it's okay so I
kind of get an audience it's like this
moment needs to happen like this or we
need to bring this element into it
before we get there because we've
already seen it so many times in a very
one-on-one or interactive experience
with theater
you